خلصت نتائج وتحقيقات الجيش الاسرائيلي في
مع عمليه معبر العوجه او نتانا الحدود مع
مصر في الثالث من الشهر الجاري الى وجود
عده اخفاقات واكد قائد القياده الجنوبيه
بالجيش الاسرائيلي اليعايزر توليدانو
ضروره تصحيحها واستخلاص العبر منها وقد
قرر الجيش الاسرائيلي وسدد الممرات
الامنيه المقامه في السياج الحدودي على
طول الحدود مع مصر كما قرر تقليص مده
مناوبه الجنود في نقاط المراقبه من 12
ساعه الى ثمانيه من جانبه فرض رئيس هيئه
اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
عقوبات على عدد من ضباط الجيش العاملين في
القياده الجنوبيه
للمزيد تنضم الينا من القدس مراسله
الجزيره نجوان سمري اهلا بك معنا نحاول ان
نفهم السياقات التي جاءت فيها هذه
القرارات ربما والنتائج التي خلص اليها
الجيش الاسرائيلي في حادثه معبر العوجه
وايضا ما دلالاتها
نعم هذه التحقيقات بدات مباشره بعد هذه
العمليه التي قتلت فيها ثلاثه من الجنود
الاسرائيليين بالقرب من معبر العوجه او
نتسانا وفق التسميه العبريه في الثالث من
الشهر الجاري والان ينشر الجيش الاسرائيلي
نتائج هذه التحقيقات وجزء من هذه
التحقيقات كانت ايضا
بمشاركه الجانب المصري علما ان الجانب
الاسرائيلي ينتظر تسلم تقرير مفصل او
نتائج مفصله للتحقيقات التي يجريها ايضا
الجانب المصري في هذا الصدد النتائج
بعنوان العريض تدل على اخفاقات كبيره
وخطيره جدا كما يصفها الجيش الاسرائيلي
لهذا الحدث وتتمثل بالاساس اولا بعدم
اطلاع القوات الاسرائيليه لفرقه الجنود
التي تعمل على طول الحدود بوجود ممرات
سماها الجيش امنيه وهي ممرات طوارئ اقامها
الجيش الاسرائيلي في داخل السياج الحدودي
على طول الحدود مع سيناء
لانتقال القوات في بعض الاحيان الى الجانب
الاخر عند حالات الطوارئ لكن لم يتم على
الاطلاق ابلاغ الجنود بوجود مثل هذه
الممرات التي استخدمها الجندي المصري من
اجل الدخول الى الجانب الاسرائيلي وكذلك
لم تاخذ قياده الجيش بعين الاعتبار بان
الطرف الاخر يعرف عن وجود هذه الممرات
وباستطاعته استخدامها من جهه اخرى يقول
تقرير الجيش بانه لم تكن هناك جهوزيه
كافيه للجنود على الحدود للتعامل مع مثل
هذه الاحداث وانما تم تدريبهم اكثر على
التعامل مع حالات تهريب الاسلحه والمخدرات
وهي حوادث تحدث بشكل متكرر على طول الحدود
ولذلك هناك اخفاق ايضا في جهوزيه قوات
الجيش بالتعامل مع مثل هذه الحوادث وهناك
العديد من الاخفاقات الاخرى التي تتحدث عن
ساعات طويله لمناوبه الجنود وايضا عدد
قليل من الجنود القرارات بالاساس بفرض
اغلاق هذه الممرات ولكن بالاساس فرض
عقوبات على قاده الفرقه العسكريه والكتيبه
العسكريه واللواء انما تقول بان الجيش
يتعامل مع هذه القضيه بخطوره بالغه لانه
من النادر ان يتم فرض عقوبات على ضباط
الجيش عندما يقع قتلى في صفوف الجيش ويكون
المسؤول عن هذه العمليات بالاساس من يوصف
بانه جانب عدائي او عمليه عدائيه عبد
السلام